impeachment we're told is similar to a
coup d'etat it's a dangerous distraction
from the business of government that
it's going to cause national trauma a
constitutional crisis and even a second
American Civil War there's no reason to
believe any of this nobody likes to get
fired right but if there's any country
on earth
that's pretty comfortable with the idea
that people can be fired it's the United
States of America not only are we
basically okay with this America
actually pioneered the idea of firing
people is entertainment you're fired now
people often say that you know the
presidency is such an important job it's
such a powerful office that we depend on
it so much that the bar to removing a
president should be very high it seems
to me you know the logic works in the
opposite direction somehow we've decided
that the one job in America that gets
the most job protection is the one where
you actually get nuclear weapons which
doesn't seem at all sensible it's time
for this man is to stop to put this
behind us so the Congress can get on
with the real issue we should be
tackling real problems we could have
lower prescription drug prices today but
Pelosi won't bring those bills to the
floor cuz she's infatuated with
impeachment and we are voting today
perhaps to paralyze our government yeah
we always hear that you know impeachment
might paralyze the federal government
which you know for some of us isn't the
most terrifying prospect
the fact is the business of government
for good and for ill goes along more or
less as as it has been during an
impeachment process in fact just before
Thanksgiving the Congress voted to
reauthorize the Patriot Act and extend
NSA surveillance and metadata collection
so for better or for worse impeachment
does not paralyze the federal government
this
they modern-day coup de time this is
Vika it's not easy to make a coup
attempt boring but the Democrats found a
way it's a sham a witch-hunt
and it's tantamount to a coup they have
wanted to reverse the course of the 2016
election the impeachment thought it
would only reverse an election if it
installed Hillary Clinton in this case
instead of Mike Pence and what kind of
coup is it that replaces an elected
president with is also duly elected
hand-picked running mate I hope that we
will finally move past this nightmare
the political equivalent of capital
punishment I'm afraid it will cause a
civil war like fracture these chambers
will become the incinerator of the
Constitution our long national nightmare
a lot of people really do think this is
a national nightmare or some kind of
regicide something something that we
should only do in fear and trembling the
framers weren't nearly this emo about
impeachment impeachment is a legitimate
peaceful constitutional process by which
the people's representatives decide to
give the president an early retirement
before his term is up our limited
experience with presidential impeachment
shows that they tend to demystify the
presidency you are reminded that these
are extremely flawed human beings and
we've suffered no discernable harm from
our three prior serious attempts at
presidential impeachment and at least
one of them did quite a lot of good I
shall resign the presidency effective at
noon tomorrow post-watergate Congress's
didn't stop at driving Richard Nixon
from office they addressed a lot of the
abuses that he and his predecessors had
committed while he was in office you had
a strengthening the of the Freedom of
Information Act you had the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act to
restrict government spying
yeah the War Powers Resolution the
national emergencies act the impoundment
control act all of these flawed but
sincere efforts to put the presidency
back in its box and make impeachment
serve as what it was supposed to be as
the Federalist Papers tell us a bridle
in the hands of the legislative body on
the executive servants of the government
and the framers of the Constitution are
rolling over in their graves crying out
from heaven some of the same people who
talk about you know the wisdom of the
framers talk about the impeachment power
as if the framers just decided to
hardwire in a doomsday device into the
Constitution the framers didn't look at
it that way they saw impeachment is a
necessary constitutional safety valve or
something like an emergency brake on a
train it's not something you want to use
a weekly basis but it's nice to have the
around when you need it Ben Franklin at
the Constitutional Convention thought
that including an impeachment power was
actually favorable to the president it
provided for regular punishment of the
executive when his misconduct deserved
it and for his honorable acquittal when
he was unjustly accused I think that's
the way in which we should look at it
today
[Music]